[Musique]
bonjour ça va dit vous avez vu casimir
mais leur d'avoir des problèmes
aujourd'hui
venez avec moi je vais essayer de savoir
ce qui se passe suivez-moi
kazemi
casimir
bonjour dis donc tu m'as l'air bien ce
monsieur est ce que je peux aider à vous
je veux bien oui je cherche ce que vous
dire exactement
imagination c'est simple il suffit de
regarder dans le dictionnaire
l'imagination c'est la faculté ou la
possibilité que possèdent l'esprit
d'évoquer des images voilà casimir ah
bon bah je ne suis pas plus avancé tout
sonne pourtant tiens on prend un exemple
tu connais la chanson de l'île aux
enfants oui oui voici venu le temps des
rires des décharges d'accéder à twitter
et me souviens toi du couple est ce
jardin n'est pas loin car il suffit d'un
peu d'imagination c'est ça pour que tout
près de vous pousse ses fleurs ses rires
et ses chansons ça veut dire qu'avec un
peu d'imagination toit et les amis qui
sont chez eux vous pouvez vous croire en
train de jouer dans le jardin l'île aux
enfants tu veux a compris ça ouais mais
c'est idiot mais tais toi tais toi c'est
le producteur de l'émission qui a écrit
les paroles non mais tu n'as rien
compris quand je dis cet idiot ça veut
dire que l'exemple que tu as choisie est
idiot je ne peux pas imaginer que je
suis dingue et aux enfants puisque j'y
vis c'est vrai que tu as raison le cet
exemple est très très mal choisi pour
toi mais tu sais casimir pourquoi ne
serais-tu par toi même d'imaginer
quelque chose tu sais quand on imagine
quelque chose très fort et bien il peut
arriver qu'on voit des choses
extraordinaires
allez je te laisse casimir fusionnerait
pour voir françois bon
imaginons qu est ce que je pourrais bien
imaginer
par exemple il y a un gros orage dans
l'île aux enfants
non non non non non non non je ne veux
pas imaginer ça j'ai trop peur du
tonnerre non imaginons autre chose
mais qui par exemple qu'il va neiger
je crois
oui avec ce vent c'est pas possible j'ai
vraiment trop froid non imaginons
quelque chose d'un de plus agréable
je ne sais pas par exemple
imaginons qu'il y a des fleurs et des
feux et sur l'arbre rouge
attention
j'imagine
oh
oh que c'est beau rôle à
l'imagination est vraiment une chose
formidable
bon je vais également imaginer quand les
ballons de françois ondéron rouge et
jaune
au ils sont magnifiques voilà françois
va être content tran soir soir oui qui
est-il casimir tu as trouvé quelque
chose à imaginer oui au regard d'arbres
où je
vois rien mais je l'aï imaginé avec des
fleurs tu ne vois pas et elles sont
belles
vraiment je vois rien casimir et les
débats l'on regarde je les ai imaginé
avec des ronds jaunes et rouges
et nous vraiment casimir je t'aime je
vois rien tu sais kazim et l'imagination
peut créer beaucoup de choses pour soi
même mais les autres ne voient rien
personne d'autre que toi ne voit des
fleurs sur l'arbre rouge et des poids
sur mes balles aux personnes sauf si les
imagine cup bonjour jean marc qu'est ce
que tu veux
mais oui lequel tend peu un rouge un
verre jaune le wallon bloc jaune
montreux trois ados minable et féroce
dragon épouvantail à moineaux paul cros
l'as eu mon trottoir que je te l'âme des
oreilles à 3 mais c'est très bien tout
ça
lui redonne ce oui je ne comprends pas
il a l'air dans une colère terrible et
je ne vois personne d'autre c'est bien
ça qui m'inquiète
il se passe quelque chose d'anormal
à ce moment là le noble et beau
chevalier blanc découvre l'horrible gros
monstre derrière l'armoire
celui-ci tremble de peur et s'écrit
pitié pitié
je vous en supplie ne me fait pas mal
beau et noble chevalier blanc je ne suis
qu'un nom ribes le gros monstre pitié
je demande s'il n'est pas son nom bull
tu sais qu'il ya des gens qui parlent et
qui marchent en dormant oui oui oui tu
crois qu'il fait un cauchemar c'est pas
bête ça je crois qu'il doit avoir raison
alors allons-y
jean-françois
il paraît que c'est très dangereux de
réveiller insolente mais annoncent ils
non je n'ai aucune pitié pour toi la
star est venue de payer des crimes tu as
an le pays la douce et jolie princesse
que je dois épouser tiens qu'est ce que
vous faites là j'étais malade
attention casimir il faut surtout pas te
réveiller ça pourrait être dangereux
mais pour moi c'est ne faut pas me
réveiller je ne dors pas
oui mais c'est vrai que tu dors pas
puisque tu nous parles beurre de verre a
l'air un peu ridicules
non pas un peu complètement ridicule
mais lors casimir et qu'est ce que tu
faisais en train de parler tout seul
comme ça j'ai créé une pièce de théâtre
qui va être joué ouais à des acteurs va
bien furent pas par des kangourous et
qui seront les acteurs les meilleurs de
l'île aux enfants je crois que cette
ligne
je vois que mais aussi il s'agit de
monsieur du snav et deux mois oyo rappaz
qui roule pour moi n'a pour moi non plus
non non un tout petit rôle même pas de
la figuration à rien du tout
mes très chers amis bonjour monsieur
l'échangé d'imagés reçu ton petit mot
demandant de venir tout de suite avoue
n'être même pas revenu en courant mon
pauvre casimir je ne peux pas courir je
respirais de froisser mon costume en
toile de californie était ce si urgent
que ça non pas vraiment mais ça m'aurait
fait plaisir
casimir ci lui expliqué monsieur du snob
pourquoi il lui a demandé de venir vous
allez voir c'est formidable ac c'est
vous qui le dites très cher ami
alors de quoi s'agit-il
et bien
voila
voila voila quoi armes écoutez si vous
m'interrompez et bien je n'arriverai pas
à vous expliquer que j'ai écrit une
pièce de théâtre et que je voudrais que
vous la jouer avec moi une pièce de
théâtre à deux personnages beaucoup
d'action n'essaie de notre grandiose et
quels sont les deux personnages et bien
il y a le nom d' et beau chevalier blanc
l horrible gros mot art est bien très
très bien mais je ne sais pas encore
quel personnage vous allez jouer
les ne sait pas qui va jouer
ribes le gros noms
très difficile
il faut que les acteurs à
[Musique]
rossens bien leur personnage et hu
devraient nous raconter l'histoire et
oui ça nous permettrait de vous aider et
bien voilà
c'est l'histoire du noble et beau
chevalier blanc qui recherchent
l'horrible gros monstres pour la tuer
et d'après ce que j'ai cru comprendre le
noble chevalier blanc est très courageux
et le gros monstre hic tremblante heures
il demande pitié
alors quel rôle vous voulez vous jouer
et bien aussi c'était possiblement le
personnage qui m'intéresserait le plus
serait celui du noble est beau c'est à
dire plan c'est dommage je vous aurais
plutôt vu dans le rôle du monde mais
enfin si vous insistez je le jouerai moi
même ce sera un rôle de composition
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à me déguiser en
horrible gros monstre mais je crois que
c'est assez réussi
ne suis-je pas superbe chevalier blanc
vous êtes très bien vous êtes parfait
vous êtes superbe tous les bon allez on
va commencer à tank azimuts n'a pas
donné la fin du texte je voudrais que
dire
juste quelques gifles et c'est tout
amadou
sidibé ne le batte et pas trop forte
vous le projet sera mené la chromite
revenions comme inscrit
j'ai très peur
je suis l'horrible gros monstre et je
suis poursuivi par le beau et noble
chevalier blanc où vais-je me cacher à
une armoire cachons nous ou de 80
horrible gros montre bien que je te
contre les ongles de pied gauche nous
montre toi féroce c'est terrible dragon
ou trois féroce et terrible dragon slash
poltron épouvantail à moineaux que je te
laves les oreilles bora ayez pitié ne me
fait pas de mal beau et noble chevalier
blanc nous rend pauvre dragon non je
n'ai pas de pitié tu dois payer tes
crimes l'heure est venue tu vas vous lui
enlevez là tout est joli prince est que
je dois être prouvé d'abord elle n'est
pas solide quoi elle n'est pas jolie
s'est plus jamais assez de vous beau et
noble chevalier un scanner a trempé sa
et nissan
versa il est
[Musique]
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous ce soir pour la première fois
s'appelle l'horrible gros monstre frac
encore
le texte et de casimir à prendre la mise
en scène d'occasion
et blanc du gros monstre joué par quasi
vide
[Applaudissements]